e.t exclusive mama june after felony
drug charges and rehab
there was a point where you and geo you
spent over 150
000 on drugs is that right a lot more
than that
like 10 times more than that um yeah
hold on
you're telling me you spent a million
dollars on drugs over
like the last year the last year of our
nation we're now
like six over 16 months clean and
i don't think about those things mama
june is now trying to make things right
with her kids
pumpkin who's 21 and 15 year old ilana
who the world knows as honey boo boo why
wasn't you there
why wasn't you there in the moments that
i needed you most
june when you had to sit down with your
children you had to hear them
talk about how they were struggling
how'd that make you feel
i mean as a parent you don't want to
hear that um
but you know i i'm glad that they were
able to express that and that we
are starting to move forward june you
did a show about
reshaping your body have you come to
peace with that now and is that kind of
in your past yeah i am okay with where i
am i've thought about doing what they
call revision
surgery because in code i have gained
like 100 pounds
how much coffee did we eat
it's clogged up with sprinkles like now
well on mama june road to redemption
airing fridays on we tv
we see pumpkin is expecting baby number
two and alana a high school junior this
fall
might be in love so how is that alana
having a boyfriend
having a is i like it she's starving
like him and ella are the best of
friends he comes over for like dinners
and stuff he's very respectful
he is pumpkin approved but after five
seasons of honey boo boo and five of
mama june's spin-offs
are they ready to give it all up i am
ready to
walk away from it and live a normal life
it may be
close to the time for us to just to kind
of
kind do the kardashians bow out
and say thank you we appreciate it what
more is there to film